today on the matt walsh show in the most
egregious case of big tech censorship
yet
amazon has declared that it will not
sell any books which categorize
transgenderism as a mental illness
which is to say they're not going to
allow science on their website anymore
also five headlines including joe biden
deciding what sort of july 4th
celebration you're allowed to have
plus a former conservative actress goes
on an apology tour but the left is of
course
not accepting the apologies as they
never do and the stimulus bill is passed
is that any any reason to celebrate
we'll talk about that in our daily
cancellation
we'll also discuss the renewed
controversy over women in the military
all of that
and more today on the matt walsh
[Music]
[Applause]
there are show problems that you
experience in life that you might think
well there's no solution you just have
to live with it
uh and oftentimes that's not the case
one of those hair loss
you don't have to live with hair loss
there is a solution and you should
pursue it
80 million men and women in the us
experience thinning hair yet it's still
not openly talked about
which can make going through it feel
scary and stressful and that just adds
to the problem
neutral fall is formulated with potent
botanicals to help your hair grow as
strong as you are and it's physician
formulated to be 100
drug free on top of thicker stronger
hair without lasers or chemicals
neutral falls ingredients may also help
you get a handle on better sleep
stress response skin nails and libido
you can visit neutral fall.com and take
the hair wellness quiz for customized
product recommendations
to put the power to grow thicker
stronger hair back into your hands
in clinical studies this is what you
need to know 72 percent of men saw more
scalp coverage and 86
of women saw improved hair growth after
six months that's what it comes down to
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show
by going to nutrafall.com and using
promo code walsh to save 20
off your first month subscription this
is their best offer available anywhere
and it's only available to us customers
for a limited time
plus free shipping on every order get 20
off at nutrafall.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l-com promo code walsh for
hair as strong as you are
so a few weeks ago amazon without
warning or explanation removed from its
website all copies of a book
authored by ryan t anderson titled when
harry became
sally responding to the transgender
moment now
anderson's uh work excellent work offers
a
scholarly thoughtful science-based
criticism
of gender theory advocating therapy for
those who experience gender confusion
rather than drugs and surgery the book's
page on barnes noble
on their website where for the moment
it's still available
offers this description i want to read
this to you just so you understand what
this book is really all about
the description is when harry became
sally provides thoughtful answers to
questions arising from our transgender
moment
drawing on the best insights from
biology psychology and philosophy ryan
anderson
offers a nuanced view of human
embodiment a balanced approach to
public policy on gender identity and a
sober assessment of the human cost of
getting human nature wrong
this book exposes the contrast between
the media's sunny depiction of gender
fluidity
and the often sad reality of living with
gender dysphoria
it gives a voice to people who cried uh
tried to transition by changing their
bodies
and found themselves no better off
especially troubling are the stories
told by adults
who were encouraged to transition as
children but later regretted
subjecting themselves to those drastic
procedures
so this is far from a polemical diatribe
okay it's in other words it's not the
kind of thing that i would have written
and there's certainly nothing hateful or
bigoted about it
yet it was apparently blacklisted by the
world's largest bookseller ostensibly
for violating amazon's hate speech
policies
but no further explanation was offered
until this past thursday yesterday
when the company provided more details
on his decision
to get rid of the book in a letter to
republican senators
with their reasoning laid out in greater
detail
we now know that the situation is even
worse than it first appeared
now that they've explained it it's even
worse than you thought
the letter from amazon's vice president
of public policy brian
uh huseman says quote as a bookseller we
provide our customers with access to a
variety of viewpoints
including books that some some customers
may find objectionable
amazon works hard to ensure customers
have a great shopping experience and
access to the widest and most diverse
cross-section
of written and spoken word in retail
today that said we reserve the right not
to sell certain content
all retailers make decisions about what
selection they choose to offer as do we
as to your specific question
about when harry became sally we have
chosen not to sell books that frame
lgbtq plus identity as a mental illness
now huzman is telling the truth about
amazon selling books with a variety of
viewpoints
mind comp for example is still for sale
on their site
hitler's viewpoints are still considered
acceptable enough
to warrant inclusion in amazon's catalog
but scientific facts about
transgenderism are not
they say that anderson's book can't be
sold because it frames lgbt identities
as mental illness but the problem is
that
first of all anderson doesn't actually
call transgender people mentally ill in
his book
just a little little uh you know a
little minor detail there
he doesn't really say that but second
and most importantly
gender dysphoria is a mental illness
the american psychiatric association's
manual of mental disorders the dsm
lists gender dysphoria as a mental
disorder
it's right there you can check for
yourself now
i do hesitate to use the dsm to prove
the point here because
the apa frequently changes the dsm for
political and ideological reasons
they've been doing that for decades
in fact the category of gender dysphoria
is itself
a reflection of political changes this
is a that phrase and that categorization
is part of political sort of political
evolution
um in our approach to this issue 30
years ago the dsm listed transsexualism
as a disorder
that was changed to gender identity
disorder i think in 1994 i believe
and then a couple of years ago gender
identity disorder was changed to gender
dysphoria
and the point of the latest change was
to label as disordered
the distress that a person feels from
their perception that their body and
their gender don't align
rather than to label the perception
itself as disordered okay
so you see the needle they're trying to
thread there but
no scientifically coherent justification
was given for any of these changes
and that's because in my view the
changes were made not for scientific but
for ideological reasons
be that as it may the real problem that
the left
and therefore amazon has with anderson's
book
isn't that he considers gender identity
disorder or gender dysphoria as we now
call it until we have to call it
something else again in you know five
years
um it's not that he calls it a mental
disorder but that he doesn't
but that he doesn't advocate drugs and
surgery to treat it
that's the real problem for them
anderson's view
which is the most humane compassionate
and scientifically valid view
on this subject by far is that those who
perceive
themselves to be in the wrong body
should be helped
okay yes we should help them their
feelings are real
nobody's denying that at least i'm not
denying that ryan t anderson's not
denying that
what they say that they feel they really
do feel that way and it is causing them
to stress
profound distress and they should be
helped through therapy and counseling to
accept themselves for who they are
they should be helped to love their own
bodies rather than
changing their bodies to resemble
something or someone else
now and probably the most disturbing
example of orwellian rhetorical
manipulation that we've seen yet
the left has taken the calling this
position
conversion therapy
okay they call that conversion therapy
now that is
therapy to help a person accept
themselves for who they are
is conversion we're told now
whereas giving a boy hormone pills and
then eventually performing surgery on
his genitals
to make them resemble the genitalia of a
different sex is not conversion
but affirmation they say
so again just just to review the
orwellian rules here if you believe that
a person who's gender confused should be
given therapy to accept themselves for
who they are
you are advocating conversion therapy
but if you believe in giving someone
drugs and hormones
giving a boy drugs and hormones so that
he grows breasts and then performing
surgery in his genitals you are
advocating affirmation
according to amazon this view which
you know validates and deepens confusion
the view that we should
quote affirm uh gender by performing
surgery
that deepens confusion rather than
alleviate it
according to amazon that's not only the
right view
but it's the only view that should be
allowed to be expressed and disseminated
so understand the consequences here
because they are
dire amazon is far and away the largest
bookseller in the world
if they declare a certain viewpoint
forbidden
that means it'll eventually be erased
from publication completely
and amazon obviously knows that
publishers aren't going to publish books
that amazon's not going to sell
the objective is and the effect will be
to simply prevent people from being
exposed to the other side that is
the scientifically and morally
defensible side of the gender argument
now an interesting question is why are
they doing this with the gender topic
and not
others i mean why are all other
conservative books even on controversial
topics allowed to remain you can go to
amazon right now you can buy
conservative books on
gun rights and and immigration and taxes
and
even abortion i mean all that stuff is
there still there
why are they taking this book down on
this topic
well the first answer is don't count
your chickens this is just the beginning
the second though is that the left
recognizes how
fundamental this issue is how much they
gain
by winning it and also
they recognize at some level how totally
and
utterly indefensible their position on
the topic is
they cannot engage with anderson's
viewpoint
they simply cannot defend the idea that
children with gender confusion
should be drugged and mutilated they
can't defend it
they know they can't they can only
defend it in a vacuum where no other
viewpoints are expressed
and even there they can barely defend it
so that's what this is about that's what
they're doing right now
all of this is about creating the vacuum
where only their views are hurt
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
now i want to tell you about true
underdog podcast you know raised in a
trailer park with no clear path to
success kicked out of high school
multiple times and faced with becoming a
father and his team's jason waller
is the definition of a true underdog
after hearing the words know where you
can't too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies with his most
recent venture power home solar
skyrocketing on a path to becoming a
billion dollar enterprise
you can join the podcast as waller a
four-time entrepreneur of the year
shares motivational tips uh inspiring
stories and business building lessons
from the ground up he shares his life
experiences
and that of his high profile guests to
help others better themselves as waller
will tell you there is
no elevator to success the climb only
happens one step at a time
let every 200 dog podcast be that step
that elevates you
uh that's what you have to do learn
about failure learn about
entrepreneurship what about never
quitting or making excuses it's real
it's raw it's motivational that's the
true underdog podcast
so you can go right now and check out
the true underdog podcast
at trueunderdog.com or you can look at
it anywhere or hear it anywhere you get
your podcast all right this is pretty
exciting i get to do
my first i think it's my first matt
walsh show
retraction and clarification this is
when you know you've really grown up
and become a full-grown man when you get
to do this so yesterday on the show i
said that
alabama was passing uh that abortion ban
and it's actually not alabama it's
arkansas so i knew it was one of those a
states down south you know one one of
those two
but that was a mistake and i just want
to say
i take no responsibility for this
mistake whatsoever
and um if you know if it caused you any
distress
i mean really you owe me an apology get
off my case about it
i take no it's not my fault i was only
going based on what i read
now granted i was reading the notes that
i wrote for myself but even so
no responsibility but there's the
clarification
i covered that base at least okay number
one from the daily wire it says
president joe biden officially signed
the american rescue plan
into law on thursday afternoon making
the official enactment of the 1.9
trillion dollar stimulus bill and his
first major legislative initiative one
day ahead of schedule
the bill you like how we just say the
word trillion now like it's like it's
nothing we're so used to
saying oh yeah we spend 1.9 trillion
trillion here trillion there
we have no concept of how
enormous these numbers are literally
incomprehensible these numbers that you
you can't
comprehend how big a trillion dollars
we spend like it's nothing the bill
biden's first major legislative
initiative provides hundreds of billions
of dollars for states and local
governments sends individuals
uh 1400 relief checks to the majority of
american
americans that extends a 300 boost to
unemployment benefits until early
september
plan also provides uh 28.6 billion
dollars for restaurants 50 billion for
cover 19 testing and contact tracing
and 15 billion dollars for vaccine
distribution
um as among and we haven't even the
things i've listed there we haven't even
made it to a trillion yet not even close
to that
so there's a lot more and there's a lot
of there's a lot of pork a lot of
pet projects from the left that are
being
um that are being added into this and
that's the thing that that most
conservatives are complaining about is
all the pork and all the other things
have nothing to do with cover 19
that are that are added to this bill and
yes
let's complain about that uh i that's
something worthy of
of our complaints even if they don't
amount to anything but my
my really is my real issue is with the
stimulus itself
why are we giving
uh why are we spending billions and
billions more
to once again send out checks to people
many of whom
didn't lose their job and are suffering
no particular financial hardship
from the pandemic now yes don't get me
wrong
there are lots of people millions of
people who did lose their job
and are suffering extraordinary
financial hardship should we help those
people absolutely
the government took their jobs away the
government owes them money
okay that's uh that's a real entitlement
in the sense that they are entitled to
the help because the government did this
let's help those people i have no no
issue with that
but there are millions of people we're
sending checks to for no reason
they they're doing fine yeah it was it's
been a tough year for all of us but
you didn't lose your job if you didn't
lose your job and
you suffered no particular financial
hardship
why should you get money why should you
get paid because there was a pandemic
but that's what we're doing they they
set the um
you know they they determine this based
on income level everybody under a
certain income level
gets money we are governed by absolute
children what
what a ridiculous stupid way of handling
this
it's like someone says there's a
pandemic what should we do um
give people money well what people
doesn't matter just
give them money no it does matter it
matters a lot who you give it to
yeah would it be difficult to actually
uh find and single out the people who
need it who lost their jobs yeah it'd be
hard to do
but do the hard thing i'd rather you do
the hard and difficult thing
and then we spend the money in a way
that's meaningful instead of spending
billions of dollars for no reason at all
you might as well throw it on a burn
pile and set it on fire
all these people on social media now
and i get it right like they're they're
celebrating oh i got my check coming
i'm gonna go buy some video games okay i
you know i i'm not saying like if you
get the check i'm not saying you should
send it back or whatever because you
send it back the government's just going
to waste it on something else so
um sure go ahead they send it to you
might as well spend it um
and i'm not i'm not suggesting you
should yourself go out and burn it uh
you know to make some sort of statement
the money's already been spent so what
else are you gonna do so i get it
i don't begrudge people for being you
know for for using the money but
but but still really really dumb plan
really dumb okay uh
number two stacy dash who's an actress
former fox news contributor i guess now
former former conservative and she's on
a bit of an apology tour trying to
make her way back into left's good
graces she did an interview with i think
it was dailymailtv
uh talking about you know her experience
as a conservative
and um we'll play that and then we'll
talk about the left's reaction to this
but let's play the interview first here
she is
i've lived my life being angry you know
i'm
which was what i was on fox news you
know i was the angry
conservative black woman and
at that time in my life
it was uh who i was
and i realized in 2016
that anger is unsustainable
and it will destroy you
and you know what people don't know is
that i made a lot of mistakes
and because of that anger being a
supporter of trump
you know has put me in some kind of
box that i do not belong in i don't hate
anyone i don't you know
i don't know where that comes from and
well i he's not the president
so i'm going to give the president
that we have right now a chance
so nothing that she's saying there is
terribly unreasonable and
i mean i don't know really anything
about her if she feels like she was too
angry or she had been consumed by anger
or something like that then um
[Music]
then and you know she wants to make that
change
more power to you but the thing is
if you're trying to get back into the
into mainstream
good graces looking for forgiveness from
the left
i mean how many times do we go over this
on the show it's not going to happen
the only way the way that i found out
about this is that her name was trending
on twitter i clicked on the name and
before i could even find the interview
or what it was referring to it was just
a whole bunch of people
thousands of people saying basically
to stacy um
stacy dash kiss our ass like
your your apology is not accepted it's
not gonna be accepted we don't accept
you back
uh you even if you've changed your mind
you at one point
expressed views that we disagree with
and you express them publicly and that
is an
unforgivable sin from our perspective on
the left and that's that's simply the
way it goes
it is something to keep in mind if you
go if you're going to go out
in public and express any kind of
anti-leftist views i think it's a great
thing to do i do it every single day
but just know there's no going back from
it
it'll never it doesn't matter once you
do it it's the unforgivable sin
and so that crowd that
they're you're never going to be friends
with them they're never going to accept
you
and that's fine that's fine with me
but you got to know you got to know what
you're getting yourself into
all right number three um from the daily
wire it says
victor obials a translator from spain
was commissioned to provide a
translation of amanda gorman's
viral the hill we climb poem after
completing the project however
uh this this from the daily wire i don't
know if i said that after completing the
project however he said that the
publisher had rejected
the translation saying that they wanted
a translator who was a woman
young activist and preferably black
according to bbc news victor whose
previous work includes translations of
shakespeare and oscar wilde
was asked to translate gorman's poem
what a step down
he goes from translating shakespeare to
amanda gorman
but he's not he's translated
shakespearean oscar wilde but
uh he's not worthy he's not worthy of
the great amanda gorman
he was asked to translate gorman's poem
in a four by oprah winthrop in free uh
winfrey oprah in free oprah winfrey
several weeks ago
but the editor of the barcelona
publisher universe told spain's fa news
agency on wednesday that after the
translation was complete
the company received a request from a
u.s group viking books for the work
work uh to be carried out by a female
activist with african-american origins
now if this sounds a little bit familiar
to you this is actually the second
controversy
surrounding a translation of amanda
gorman's work
this comes soon after dutch translator
with a name that i'm not even going to
try to pronounce
who is outspoken on issues including
gender equality and mental health and
identities
identifies as non-binary and uses the
pronouns they them step
down after
you know he was going to translate some
of amanda gorman stuff
but this was declared also completely
wrong
in fact this was declared
incomprehensible
critics were saying it's
incomprehensible that they would choose
a non-black non-activist to translate
her work
i have to say i kind of understand where
they're coming from this is why
you know i threw out recently my copy of
uh
crime and punishment i threw it in the
trash in disgust
because i don't want any dostoevsky book
that isn't
translated by a russian epileptic ex-con
from the 19th century
you know i need someone who understands
his lived experiences
and if you can't find you they're you
know if there's no re
give me one good reason give me one good
reason why you can't find
right now a russian epileptic ex-con for
19th century to translate his work
no good excuse
of course really the main question
though is uh aside from the the utter
absurdity of all this
the main question is why are we
translating her drivel in the first
place
you're translating it into other
languages
this stuff again is not even poetry
and it's bad enough when you listen to
it
because with slam poetry it's all about
the performance that's all it is
it has to be performed in such a way as
to seem profound and meaningful
when you read it on the page you see it
for how empty and shallow it really is
so for example here is i think this is
the poem that all the controversy is
over
the hill we climb was that the um
first of all it wasn't the hillary climb
a miley cyrus song from like 10 years
ago or is that something else
but i think this was the inaugural so
the inaugural poem which i think is the
hillary clinton could be wrong about
that
but i went and looked up the text of the
the poem that she gave at the
inauguration
and let me i'll just read i'll read to
you the the lyrics or whatever we would
call the text of that poem
part of it anyway she said when day
comes we ask ourselves
where can we find light in this
never-ending shade
the lost we carry a sea we must wade
we've braved the belly of the beast
we've learned that quiet isn't always
peace
and the norms and notions of what just
is
isn't always justice and yet the dawn is
ours
before we knew it somehow we do it
somehow we've weathered and witnessed a
nation that isn't broken
but simply unfinished now i feel like i
didn't do my point justice here because
i performed that
in such a powerful way so i may have
i may have undermined my own point you
may have just gotten wrapped up in my
performance i think i did a better job
than she
but did i i really wanted to hear you
wanted you to hear the
the words listen to all the cliches
one cliche after another the belly of
the beast
what are you doing putting that into
your poem
this is like if if you are
a sixth grader writing poetry for a
writing class
their teacher this would be a c-plus at
best
and they'd be circling lines like that
and saying no no don't put this don't
put a cliched phrase
in your poem the belly of the beast
the s the dawn the dawn will be here
soon
but one a parade of cliches
and this is now this is the height of
our
poetic accomplishment as a nation now
she is our greatest what does that tell
you amanda gorman
is our greatest poet
she's the great poet of this generation
that
okay um moving on number four joe biden
gave a speech last night
didn't watch the speech don't care that
much but there's one clip i wanted to
play for you
uh and here it is let's listen i need
you
i need every american to do their part
and that's not hyperbole i need you i
need you to get
vaccinated when it's your turn and when
you can find an opportunity
and to help your family your friends
your neighbors
get vaccinated as well because here's
the point
if we do all this if we do our part
if we do this together by july the 4th
there's a good chance you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood
and have a cookout at a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
that doesn't mean large events with lots
of people together but it does mean
small groups will be able to get
together
after this long hard year that will make
this
independence day something truly special
where we not only mark our independence
as a nation
but we begin to mark our independence
from this virus but to get there
we can't let our guard down this fight
is far from order
from over as i told the woman in
pennsylvania i'll tell you the truth
a july 4th with your loved ones is the
goal
first of all joe calm down back off
um i need you i need you baby i need you
he thought he was talking to like a
secretary for a second just don't
joke ease up a little bit
uh second every time you hear this guy
speak and you watch it especially
you really get the impression even if
what he is saying is basically coherent
as it was there
uh oftentimes it isn't but even if it is
you really get the impression that he
doesn't know what he's saying
there's this i'm not i don't say this as
a joke there is this
really disturbing vacant look in his
eyes
where you can tell he doesn't he's not
with it he's not there
and then third um
we might he might give us permission on
july 4th
2021 to gather with small groups
of family and friends he might give us
permission to do that
if he decides in his graciousness his
uh his magnanimous if he decides that
he's going to allow maybe he will
of course i assume still masked we'll
have to wear the masks
well i can tell you joe that i was with
a large group of unmasked people for
july 4th
last year and by the way nobody we all
survived
we all made it through and i'll be doing
that again this year
no matter what you say
because your ideas of
what i can and can't do your opinions of
what i can and cannot do
are immaterial to me are irrelevant i
don't care
and i would hope that we're all at that
point now
okay a couple other things um on a
friday i want to get through all of
these
yeah i wanted to play this too i've had
this for a couple of days a real quick
clip
from the governor of texas
greg abbott who
for some reason has decided to launch a
campaign
against alternative social media
platforms not the big ones not twitter
or facebook but
the alternative ones where some people
on the right some conservatives are
going
he's he's attacking those platforms and
here he is announcing that plan let's
watch anti-semitic platforms like gab
have no place in texas and certainly
do not represent texas values what does
represent texas values
is legislation like this by
representative king
and representative goldman that fights
anti-semitism in texas
what are you guys doing down there in
texas you get a lot right but what are
you doing with this guy
how's this the guy you chose i mean he
goes from
supporting the lockdowns and the masking
for a year and then he lifts it
and he expects everyone to applaud him
and thank him oh thank you dear leader
thank you for for removing these chains
that you put on us to begin with
and now he's going after gab that's
the republican governor of texas is
launching a campaign against gab
in an alternative social media site
where some conservatives are going
that's what you're focused on
not big tech censorship not amazon
you know taking down scientific
information because it doesn't work with
their political agenda
what about pornhub victimizing children
and women what about them
i mean there are a lot of if you're if
you're looking to to go on a crusade
against
against websites there are a lot of good
ones you could choose
gab
this you guys like i said
who am i to judge but um
not the best decision with this guy down
there in texas number five finally the
new york post reports
scientists have begun to lay plans to uh
for repopulation
starting with a sperm bank on the moon
in what they're calling a modern global
insurance policy mechanical engineers
have proposed
that humans establish a repository of
reproductive cells
sperm and ova from 6.7 million of
earth's species including humans
the proposed bank or ark would be
beneath the moon's surface
as our planet faces natural disasters
drought asteroids and
potential for nuclear war scientists say
that humans must set their sights on
space travel to preserve life as we know
it
and um the author of the study
jekin thanga says earth is naturally a
volatile environment
which is why they want to earth is an is
a volatile environment which is why we
want to put it on on the moon
on the moon there's there's no
environment there's no atmosphere
wild swings in temperature like it goes
from like 250
degrees to negative 250 degrees uh
depending on on um
where it's positioned in relation to the
sun
i i don't know it doesn't seem like the
most practical plan in the world but i
could be wrong
and the the main problem though is that
you're just asking right
you're just asking for aliens to take
these things and do experiments
you're you're opening the invitation
you're putting this stuff up on the moon
is this like bait or something to lure
the aliens in
if that was the plan then maybe i could
support it
you are all but guaranteeing think about
this you are guaranteeing that a future
generation of humans
are going to be raised in matrix pods on
planet
zeptacon or whatever all because of this
reckless reckless
now a word from one of our favorite
sponsors rock otto you know if you have
any kind of car trouble you need auto
parts you got a couple different ways
you can go about it one of those ways
the old-fashioned way get in your car
drive down to the auto parts store go
looking around for what you can
you know through their limited selection
you're gonna find stuff that's way too
expensive go through that whole
rigmarole or
you can just go to rockauto.com it's so
much easier than walking into a store
and dealing with all of that hassle you
have access to rockauto.com at your desk
in your pocket you've got it there with
you all the time rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible
they're not going to change the prices
they're not going to you know try to
figure out how much they think they can
get out of you and charge you more it's
not going to work that way rockauto.com
is a family business
an honest business they've been serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
you go to rockauto.com to shop for auto
and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
again the prices at rockauto.com are
reliably low
all the time their selection is great
best price best selection what more
could you ask for
you got to go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and write walsh in there how
did you hear about his box
so they know that we sent you um all
right let's move on to reading the
youtube comments this is from john mark
fleming says
listening to matt walsh to the to match
show is like getting to friday it's all
business with ben
analysis analysis with nulls but
listening to the matt walsh show is like
sitting down to a cold one
with your disgruntled and gloomy yet
charming dad
i think i'll take that as as a
compliment but you're still banned of
course
bill al benassar says matt's beard
reminds me of a physics teacher i once
had
who would turn his heat on just to annoy
his neighbors upstairs because all the
heat went upstairs matt would 100
do that i would absolutely do that
that's great uh mary joseph says
just popped in to leave a like catch you
later
well i i do appreciate that and again if
you're watching this on
youtube make sure to make sure to smash
that like like button
friends and hit subscribe to the
notification bell if you're listening on
itunes make sure to subscribe
i'm going to keep pestering you about
this until i have 40 million youtube
subscribers you will hear me continue to
say this
so i do appreciate that mary but at the
same time you said you popped in to
leave a like and didn't watch the show
so
um i guess i'm not good enough for you
so you're not good enough for me you're
banned
taylor stewart says unfortunately matt i
know so many people waiting around for
fouchy to tell them
when they can live again sad uh
yeah i guess i don't this has been the
weird thing for me
we all have our own bubbles right and uh
this has been the weird thing for me
through the pandemic is that
i don't personally know a lot of people
like that people in my family people i
work with uh
most of my friends you know aren't
aren't like that
you know we've all been basically living
our normal lives this entire time
but i certainly know that those people
are out there and i hear from
from folks all the time their family
members are are
in the really paranoid camp and so
that's got to be tough to deal with
uh will stewart says question for
friday's show is matt wearing skinny
jeans again today i wasn't wearing
skinny jeans in the first place those
were not skinny jeans
4 20 snack time says are you still
wearing your jeggings they were not
jeggings and they were not skinny jeans
they were regular jeans
josh hidalgo says matt sjw equals matt
skinny jeans walsh
mathman says just wear your skinny jeans
at 500 000 subscribers they're not i
don't have skin i can't wear them
because i don't have them i have regular
jeans
you know okay i go to the store i go to
the the pants department
and i pick up some jeans that's all i do
the judgment and the shaming is out of
control
you're all banned of course i truly do
believe that
uh we can make the world a better place
just by reading books and i even though
it's written down
here for me to say i really do believe
it i actually think that that's the case
rather than rather than you know social
media watching tv watching netflix if we
if we
all spend more time reading books we'd
be more interesting and more
intelligent people um and there's a
crisis of stupidity in this culture
that's one of the ways that you solve it
if you agree with me and you've been
looking for a new title to check out
look no further the new york times
bestselling author and renowned podcast
host
none other than our very own andrew
clavin just released the third and final
installment
in the another kingdom series and this
is the last one
if you read the other two and you loved
it you got to pick up this one if you
haven't read the other two
then buy the other two and this one read
all three the first two books in the
series didn't disappoint so i'll
personally be sitting down to find out
how this latest one concludes uh how it
all comes together the emperor's sword
is what it's called it's now available
to purchase online
you can go to amazon.com and search the
emperor sword go right now amazon.com
andrew clavin's latest the emperor's
sword also uh i want to tell you about
on election night you know we we
announced that candace owens will be
joining the daily wire with a new show
and now the wait is finally over or it's
almost over anyway
march 19th friday march 19th the new
show
candace will premiere um and we know
about candace she's the founder of the
blexit foundation
worked to change the narrative that
surrounds america's minority communities
she's also the author of the new york
times bestseller blackout how black
america can make its second escape from
the democrat plantation
she's done a lot of stuff a very
interesting person always with
interesting ideas and now
candice will be available exclusively to
daily wire members so if you're not yet
a member go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code candice to get 25
off again that's dailywire.com slash
subscribe
and use code candace to get 25 off now
let's get to our daily cancellation
now while the leaders of other countries
are focused on
you know making their militaries into
more effective and deadlier fighting
machines
which thrive at the central task of
killing the enemy the folks in charge of
our military
have an entirely different set of
priorities it would seem for them
america's greatest adversary isn't china
or any other world power
but intolerance and the best way to
defeat intolerance
is through the promotion of diversity
and inclusion
now once you understand that these are
the new priorities of a military that
has long been a petri dish for leftist
social experimentation
the events of this past week become
slightly more comprehensible
without this background understanding it
might seem shocking and bewildering
that a search for the phrase military
leaders in google's news tab
delivers not articles about those
leaders developing devastating new
battlefield technology or doing anything
else to make the u.s
safer and more secure but dozens of
headlines like this one from the
military times
it says senior leaders dunk on tucker
carlson's misogynistic comments about
maternity flight suits
nbc news tucker carlson slammed by
military leaders
for mocking pregnant service members
yahoo news
pentagon takes unprecedented shot at
tucker carlson
for dissing military diversity
this is what the pentagon is focused on
the crisis that's attracted the
attention of these fearless warriors
is as the headline suggests a
politically
incorrect opinion expressed by a cable
news host
on his show a few days ago tucker
carlson had an appropriately derisive
reaction to president biden's remarks on
international women's day
where biden discussed his plans to get
more women involved in combat including
pregnant women
and part of his plan biden said is to
offer maternity flight suits and to
update hair style requirements
here's biden explaining you know
some of some of it's relatively
straightforward work
where we're making good progress
designing body armor that fits women
properly
tailoring combat uniforms for women
creating maternity flight suits and
updating
updating requirements for their
hairstyles
and some of it is going to take and
uh you know is an intensity
of purpose and mission to really change
the culture and habits
that cause women to leave the military
women are making sure more diverse
candidates are considering
being considered for career advancing
opportunities at every single level
the women aren't penalized in their
careers for having children
that women aren't just token members
but integral parts throughout all
branches and all divisions
that vacant look once again a carlson's
point about these plans is simply that
they don't seem designed to actually
make the military
better at what the military is supposed
to do
protect the country and kill the enemy
these are changes based not on science
and data but ideology
here's uh here's tucker so we've got
new hairstyles and maternity flight
suits pregnant women are going to fight
our wars
it's a mockery of the us military while
china's military becomes more masculine
as it's assembled the world's largest
navy our military needs to become as joe
biden says more feminine whatever
feminine means anymore
since men and women no longer exist the
bottom line is
it's out of control and the pentagon's
going along with this again this is a
mockery of the us military and its core
mission which is winning wars
he's totally right of course
and it's likely the fact that he's right
which provoked military leadership to go
into defcon
1. the command senior enlisted leader of
the united states space command master
gunnery sergeant scott h stalker
posted a video on twitter blasting
tucker for causing drama
and arguing that the cable host has no
military experience also stalker noted
the decision to include more pregnant
women in the armed forces
was made by medical experts here's some
of that let's listen
let me tell you where he's wrong those
decisions were made by medical
professionals by commanders
and our civilian leadership that allows
for women to have more time with their
children
to recuperate to get fit and ready
to take that time that's necessary that
our medical professionals know
is needed which makes actually makes us
a more lethal
and ready and fit force ready to fight
the wars of today
and the wars of tomorrow the bottom line
is that we value women in our in our
armed forces we value the those that
have served in the past
and we value those that have served
today we value our families
in the military i want to say god bless
everyone that is serving today
god bless the women that are serving
today god bless the men and women that
are serving today
god bless our country our partners and
our allies
let's get back to work let's remember
that those opinions were made by an
individual
who has never served a day in his life
let's remember
that's all about drama tv god bless
america
semper fidelis now the problem with this
argument is that it's
beside the point the fact that tucker's
never served in the military does not
preclude him from making common-sense
observations about the military
and by the way this whole thing about
how you you can't criticize military
policy unless you serve in the military
so what you're saying is you can't
criticize the government unless you've
worked for it
i'm not sure i'm a fan of that i'm not
sure that's the most american in fact i
would say
that's about the most anti-american
opinion you could possibly express
and the fact that medical experts said
it's okay to have pregnant women
piloting aircraft
doesn't mean that it's better or even
good to have more pregnant women
piloting aircraft
i don't care if they said it's okay what
does it have to do with anything
who gives a damn about that the first
and primary
primary question the people running our
military whether civilian or enlisted
should be asking is whether any given
change will help to make the military
into a more lethal fighting force
should be the motivation behind every
change because that's the fundamental
purpose of the military
the problem isn't just that the abide
administration wants to include women in
the military
they've already been included for
decades so we're way past that
is that he wants to take active steps to
recruit more and more women
and get more of them involved in in
combat at every level
and so again we have to ask will this
make the military
better at killing the bad guys
we're not asking did the medical experts
say it's okay
we're not asking about diversity we're
not will this make the military
better at killing the bad guys if
if america was going to war with an
enemy and you could choose between
fighting an enemy
with a with a military comprised 100
percent of men
or military comprised 50 of men or 50 of
women which would you choose
to fight against
does it make the military better at
killing the bad guys when you include
more women
the answer to that question is pretty
clearly no now we can arrive at this
conclusion through the employment of
basic common sense
those who require studies to confirm
common sense judgments will be
interested to know
that the studies do indeed find that
exactly what sensible people would
expect them to find it as npr reported
in 2015
quote a year-long marine corps study
trying to understand how gender
integration
would affect combat readiness has found
that all male units were faster
more lethal and able to evacuate
casualties in less time
overall according to a summary of the
study all male squads performed better
than mixed groups in 69
of the tasks evaluated faster and more
lethal
all male squads are faster and more
lethal because men in general are faster
and more lethal
this probably explains why the navy
seals opened their ranks to women years
ago
but still no woman has managed to become
one
only the fastest and most lethal can
make it through and no woman has ever
been able to get over that bar
now admittedly i also say this is
someone who like carlson did not serve
but it seems to me that
when it comes to the us military faster
and more lethal
is good tell me if i'm wrong i'm
i didn't serve in the military that's
that's what it seems to me
that it's good if i had to choose
between making the military faster and
more lethal
or making it slower and less lethal i
would choose faster and more lethal
that's that seems better to me
if increased efforts to recruit and
evolve more and more women
will have the effect of making our
fighting forces slower and less lethal
then those efforts are bad it's that
simple
now if the other side of this argument
has evidence that in fact women make the
military more lethal then they ought to
present it
you just heard there he claimed he said
though this is
including pregnant women and giving them
time off with their kids is all part of
making us a more lethal fighting force
really how so can you explain that
i'm gonna need a little bit more than
that
but the really troubling fact is that
the other side isn't actually interested
in having an argument about what
policies will make the military better
at killing the enemy to them
killing the enemy ought not be the
central function of the institution at
all
general jacqueline van ovost also
responded to tucker carlson and
explained quote there are nearly 70 000
qualified kick-ass female
airmen from the u.s air force airmen for
years we have evolved and will continue
to evolve
shedding antiquated policies preventing
any woman from reaching their full
potential
inclusion is our strength it'll be the
difference between winning and losing
inclusion is our strength this of course
is
madness if inclusion is our strength
then why have boot camp
why have any physical or performance
standards at all
why have elite units like the seals and
the rangers
the point in all of those cases is to
exclude
to weed out the weakest and the least
capable
for the first two centuries of our
nation's existence back when our
military was toppling empires
and winning world wars it was thought
that our strength
was strength we had the baddest and
toughest the most well-trained men
and the best strategic minds to lead and
guide them and that's how we achieved
world-changing victory after
world-changing victory
but that was back when things were
allowed to have a purpose that
transcended the political
the left will not permit such trifles
anymore now all things in their control
let's face it the military is one of
those things have
the primary purpose of advancing the
leftist ideological agenda
so we will go out of our way to get
women even pregnant women into fighter
jets and onto the battlefield
and we'll recruit transgender people and
pay for their sex changes with tax money
and do a hundred other things that will
in no way make us stronger or safer as a
nation
because the powers that be have decided
that is no longer the military's job
to be a military if they are to be
warriors anymore they must be
they must be warriors of the social
justice variety
and that's how it's going to go at least
until we're invaded and conquered
and for all of those reasons the people
running our military
starting at the top with joe biden are
certainly without a doubt
canceled and we'll leave it there for
today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great weekend see you next week
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledovsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin